[Musique]
bonjour jean louis marie louise bonjour
monsieur ivory bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique et de martinique 1ère et
bonjour riverains ou vivre n vous avez
50 ans vous êtes chef d'entreprise vous
êtes c'est votre première participation
à une élection et vous allez donc
conduire la liste grand rivière avant
tout c'est bien cela brigands ua mentaux
alors avant de parler politique nous
allons essayer de vous découvrir un peu
qui êtes vous monsieur jean louis marie
louise donc je suis une avenue jean
louis de grand rivière natif de grand
rivière et je veux depuis quelques
années plus d'une dizaine d'années avec
les riverains dans les associations dans
la vie associative à la vie culturelle
sociale suprise ans j'habite dont il
viagem années 20 à nos rivières
donc ce qui me permet aujourd'hui de
devenait train avant avec des camarades
au pouvoir devrait davantage parce qu'on
prend que dans les vias s'endort un peu
alors on va revenir sur mon yvias qui
s'endort selon vos propos mais vous avez
déjà militer politiquement non je n'ai
jamais milité politiquement je les
appelle pour le moment je m'occupe déjà
de la commune et nous verrons par la
suite
alors pourquoi vous avez décidé alors de
sauter le pas et de vous présenter
alors comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure à militer dans les associations
c'est une chose mais la gouvernance en
est une autre
et aujourd'hui la population et
demandeurs de ce genre de personnes
actives à commune on ne veut plus de
figurants les acteurs donc un groupe
d'amis et de camarades devant rivière
qui ont décidé de me mettre en avant
dans cette liste pour pouvoir porter
gorille en avant les actions qui
viennent à mener a grandi à voir est ce
que si le fait que joe hachem book et il
ne se représentent plus qui vous a
décidé au nom pas du tout pas du tout si
je pense que c'est d'abord une histoire
de coeur un grand rivière comme on dit
quand il ya vente aux
c'est l'idée de ce changement pauvres en
hiver on y vient depuis 19 ans est menée
par quelqu'un je pense que qu'ils font
changement la loi permet aujourd'hui on
parle de
on parle de gouvernance lé palais pas
personnel donc on veut mener une
gouvernance participative et tout le
monde tous les habitants le banc lire
c'est ça que nous voulons veut alors
nous avait dit que qu'on s'endort à
grande-rivière qu'on ne veut plus de
figurants à grande-rivière vous voulez
de changement est à dire c'est à dire on
parle le vent est violent
jean pierre est mort ça ne bouge pas ça
ne bouge pas alors en rivière et dans
une situation de juillet août au que les
gens on voit du monde les touristes qui
arrivent et les dix derniers mois les 18
mois qui restent on est en train d'y
vernet donc c'est pas le cas on ne
devrait pas d'accident site cette
situation aujourd'hui il ya trop de
moyens qu'une sont donnés par se dire l
europe nous avons cap nord qui en place
qui offre des solutions on nous n'avons
plus le syndicat d'initiative à gand
rivières ce que nous souhaitons remettre
en place
donc tout cela nous nous tient à coeur
et avec les camarades qui m'entoure je
ne suis pas seul 1 donc nous allons
faire toutes ces choses les ennemis qui
sont là qui kid qui sont demandeurs de
ce genre de choses donc mais on a quand
même l'impression que cette commune
était une commune attractive elle
pourrait l'être davantage
d'accord je ne suis pas là pour juger
les le fonctionnement du maire en place
il a fait ce qu'il pouvait faire
aujourd'hui arrivent eux je dirais que
quand il a commencé ils avaient mon âge
1 50 ans aujourd'hui je pense que la
draille 70 je pense qu'il faut une
relève à chaque commune surtout que nous
sommes dans le grand nord
quand ils viennent c'est une destination
et j'invite tout le monde à venir 1 je
profite de l'occasion et aujourd'hui il
faudrait changer cette politique non pas
une politique dicte hâtive une politique
participative avec cette jeunesse qui
qui qui va conduire cette commune avec
la participation des gens une platine
diktat yves qu'est ce que vous entendez
par là
alors j'attends simplement
qu'aujourd'hui on parle d'eux alors
j'entends les médias venir chez vous et
parler d'eux de politique je dirais
participative participative c'est quoi
si la population qui décide
nous avons des projets qui sont menés
avant yves hier qu'ils sont aboutis
comme ce port qu'on ne peut pas utiliser
comme ses rôles yen qui sont suspendues
sur notre tête et qu'on a pas
d'électricité deux ou trois fois par
semaine tout ça c'est un stress pour
l'abus
en neuf ans il ya et nous voulons
changer tout ça allait demander aux
autorités utile ce qu'il faut faire
elle n'ose très peu de temps quelles
sont les grandes lignes de votre
programme
alors les grandes lignes de notre
programme c'est le rassemblement déjà la
première chose au niveau de deux cap
nord les consulter pour remettre en
place le syndicat d'initiative a livré à
nos aînés avant une certaine proximité
avec nos aînés avec les jeunes qui font
en souffrance qui liquide dedans il ya
et c'est ça que nous voulons mettre en
place les projets je n'aurais pas assez
de temps pour vous expliquer mais on a
des projets les gens me connaissent sur
le terrain donc c'est ça qui a fait
qu'on veut ramener quand hier une action
forte une action forte aujourd'hui eux
le la commune devant nivière souffre et
dont une souffrant terry des gens n'ont
pas le temps de de s'exprimer nous avons
des problèmes d'électricité d'eau on
veut remettre tout ça sur eux sur pied
enviro dynamité grand rivière avec eux
tout ce ou ces personnes qui seront là
et qu'ils veulent avancer comme nous
sommes sur deux ça monsieur jean louis
marie louise je vous remercie
[Musique]